hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation costly closures the
return on investment in covid19
prevention for
retail schools sports and entertainment
this webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series and i'm susie
valdez of labyrinth and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labrutz so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage to participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credit tab located
on the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr blight
adamson the founder and epidemiologist
and at the infectious economics for a
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr adamson welcome you may
now begin your presentation
wonderful thank you for having me
so my talk is going to be quite
different than a lot of the other
keynotes that you've had in this series
and i hope that it spices things up a
little bit i've got quite a few more
photos to show
than i do graphs today
so
again my name is bligh it's nice to meet
you
i'm an applied epidemiologist
and my specialty is in the prevention of
infectious diseases
so i do this with a lot of tools um it
requires me to code in 12 languages
uh to
analyze complex electronic medical
records and build a lot of math models
of the dynamic transmission of diseases
but i'm also an economist
so with that it means that
into these models and calculations
i'm also considering what the cost is of
prevention and what are the resources
required to get the outcomes that we
want
because we'll often have to make
trade-offs
and that's really important for the
design of good public policy and as
we'll talk about today
policies for private businesses
and ways that we can really
both on one side
help reopen our economy while also
really valuing and preserving health in
our population
so you know often when i'm in a room
there's a conference room table and on
one side of the table it's all the
health people
and they all
you know often
really want to maximize health at any
cost and on the other side of the table
are the economists
and they want to maximize gdp minimize
unemployment you know and get economic
recovery and productivity back again so
i end up often in the middle of those
two uh being the translator between
those two disciplines who often use
different words to describe the same
concepts in math
so
this uh is
what my screen looks like on on many
days pre pandemic
but because of this uh
very
random intersection of disciplines where
where i fall
in march early march of 2020 i was
called into fema as an emergency
responder epidemiologist
and then quickly called to to be the
lead data scientist
in the west wing of the white house
so stayed there working with um all the
health officials and economists uh
through the worst of of the spring waves
of the pandemic was incredibly difficult
but the stories about the white house
are not what i'll be sharing with you
today uh really what i want to talk
about
today
uh are things that have happened on the
other side on the on the downswing of
this pandemic
as we figure out what is life going to
look like how soon can we get things
open again
and i as someone who really loves
challenges
and trying to think of ways to do
really hard things
uh i really saw an opportunity to
help guide safe ways to do large
in-person gatherings again
now in a pandemic this seems like a
terrible idea but you know we got to
figure out how to do it some somehow
and so the focus of what i'll be talking
about today really is on decisions that
private businesses
are are making in order to gather
together large numbers of people from
different households together in person
and
really for something that happens over
and over in time so recurring events now
categories of this um you know from this
sector that we think of in the economy
can include sports
leisure events
theater
concerts uh and the ripple effects of
who this touches the job that this
touches really includes the travel
industry and the hospitality industry as
well
and so with all of the you know five
million jobs where that we are still
missing from pre-pandemic
what is it going to look like for us to
to be able to safely get things open
again
so i want to start by talking about the
nba
because of all of the major sports
leagues the nba has clearly been the
leader
in
uh beginning again
and investing the resources and taking
coronavirus very very seriously
so
what we saw uh in mid 2020 was the nba
bubble
and i'm so incredibly
impressed by
everything that the nba has done to make
data available to researchers and for
all of our scientific community to learn
from the rich data that was generated
in the nba bubble and in the nba season
last year
so
the the first thing i want to describe
is why they were able to do this so well
so
it was a time early in the spring of
march 2020 when we really didn't know
for sure what the probability was of
someone experiencing symptoms or being
asymptomatic with covid and because of
that we really didn't know how many
people were
truly becoming infected with covid
because so many of the true infections
were invisible to us especially with
that original lineage you know there
were many fewer people who were had
access to testing if they didn't have
symptoms and so a gift of the nba was
the sequential testing program that they
implemented
now they tested players and staff
every single day with pcr testing
and this really is one of the richest
data sets that that we have in the world
to understand what the beginning of the
curve of viral dynamics looks like
because unless you're testing someone
every single day when they're negative
you really don't know how long the the
uphill is of the of the
fiber load curve
and so they tested these players every
single day actually two different ways
they did a nasal swab
and they collected saliva tubes
now it's the nba's investment in yale
university that helped develop the now
known as saliva direct test
and this was an incredible gift because
it has both increased access to high
quality pcr testing in the united states
while also lowering costs
you know i like to think i like to make
the analogy of
um
you know instead of getting a fresh
direct box with like a kit to do pcr
just like you're making enchiladas for
your family when you need to make
enchiladas for the whole block party you
just need to go to the grocery store and
buy the cheapest of all the ingredients
that you can get access to and make as
many enchiladas as you can
that's how i think about pcr tests
there was a shortage of many of the
different reagents that we needed
and saliva direct
through yale and the nba was one of the
great solutions for that
and
doing these double swabs every day is
what able what helped allow
validation and development of that so
one of the early learnings that we had
really was that the
the
peak viral load for people who were
symptomatic versus asymptomatic was very
very similar and
it that meant there was a question at
the beginning are people who don't feel
any symptoms as infectious
as people who do feel symptoms and what
we learned is the answer is probably yes
they probably are very similar
but the key difference is uh between
symptomatic and asymptomatic and i think
that there's a real parallel here for
what we're now seeing among vaccinated
compared to unvaccinated individuals
is that the duration of infectiousness
was shorter for people who were
asymptomatic compared to symptomatic and
now that we have similar data from daily
pcr testing uh
now in you know the the summer and fall
of 2021 we see something very similar
vaccinated people
we're observing have a similar peak
viral load maybe a little bit lower
but their duration of infectiousness is
much shorter
so the nba has been incredibly
successful but you know at that time in
the bubble they didn't have audiences um
access was very restricted and players
didn't even have access to their
families or the staff didn't have access
to their families things were kept in
very tight lockdown
so what did things look like when we
tried to open up and all the different
sports uh sporting leagues tried to
develop their own protocols
well so i as a member of the covid
sports and society working group i have
the privilege of meeting every week with
sports leagues to to understand what
policies and decisions they're making
for their teams um what are the outcomes
they're seeing and
how often are we seeing outbreaks
associated with different with different
sets of policies you know so
we can go back to
um the
july of this year to
a game that was try about to become very
famous which was the yankees against the
red sox i think this was july 15th
but
shockingly announced to everyone the
game is cancelled you know all the
tickets that had been sold you know no
one's allowed to come and people were
just
devastated
and this was one of many games
not just in baseball but across many
different sporting leagues that even
with
wearing masks doing testing
we still continue to see outbreaks
now i will say that
it has allowed us to to learn a lot of
things
one of them is that we still don't see
evidence
that other than other than hockey
that transmissions are happening on the
field or on court
we're the main one of the riskiest
places we are seeing for
transmission of sars kobe 2
you know which won't surprise you at all
is in the locker room
and sometimes in transportation if
there's not good filtration or open
windows
so what does this look like for for
other groups you know theater has tried
to reopen uh we have uh
maybe half of broadway in new york city
reopened again
yet even still with uh testing different
testing strategies
uh this was
the same week that the this is four days
after the yankees versus the red sox
were cancelled because of an outbreak
we see in london that andrew lloyd
webber knew cinderella was also
cancelled
but in this case just because of one
positive case now it is interesting to
see how different countries policies
affect and pressure and put risk on
different businesses
at this point in time
the uk had a different quarantine policy
after exposure to cobit than the united
states
and so it would have actually been much
more difficult for production to stay
open in london than in us at that point
in time
and i think the economics of this are
really interesting because you know each
business has to think through
you know how much am i willing to spend
on prevention you know it just seems
like testing could be really expensive
and you know that's out of my budget
and you i really like to think through
what's the probability that you're going
to have to cancel this concert because
of an outbreak or this game or this this
show
now it's much easier i think in when we
when we think about the sphere of
entertainment tv and film
really do fall within a different
category for two reasons one
when there's an outbreak of covid on a
tv or film set it does it often costs
millions of dollars a day
because of the
equipment rentals
and extending the schedules but it can
often happen without anyone in the the
outside world knowing about it
and the number of people it impacts is
much smaller than
the way that we think about live
entertainment events
where thousands and sometimes tens of
thousands of people are affected if an
event is cancelled that was intended to
be live
so you know on broadway an average
broadway show within one week has an a
gross revenue of you know over a million
dollars
and so if there were an outbreak in a
cast in production the cost
to cancel that means you know
immediately losing a million dollars of
ticket sales
so
then all of a sudden if you multiply the
probability of canceling
by the amount of money that you will
lose if you have to cancel
it becomes much easier to define the
threshold of how much you might be
willing to pay to reduce the likelihood
of having an outbreak in a cancellation
so then it becomes easier to budget for
copious safety managers
signage appropriate ppe
and training i didn't include training
on my list but that's an important one
too
and then testing i think
i see many groups who
uh for cast and crew
uh or you know concert performers or
players of these different live events
uh
have ranged in frequency of testing from
once a week
to multiple times a day
now i do see for
uh individuals who to do their job on a
stage or a court or a field who must
take off their mask
often weekly testing
is not sufficient to identify cases
and so i do see frequency ranging
between you know three to six days per
week of pcr testing many of these core
individuals in order to pick up a
positive early enough that you can pull
them out and prevent an infection
so you know those costs can run high
even on tv and film sets we're seeing
budgets uh you know per tv and film
production around four hundred thousand
dollars a week just on pcr testing alone
so this is um you know a very uh
delicate balance of costs and benefits
that that these productions uh and and
leagues have to make regularly
so what really are the attributes that
we're thinking about with super
spreading events uh you know it's been
something that's uh been hard to predict
you know the the heterogeneity of
infectiousness among people has been
something different about covid19
compared to other viruses that we've
seen
you know it's
we see generalizations and describing it
as
you know most people with covid don't
spread it to very many people but some
people with covid spread it to a lot of
people
and i think we've done a good job
describing environmental attributes
that are associated with super spreading
events like being indoors
you know choosing not to wear a mask
but there are also many attributes of
the individual hosts themselves that
relate to
you know how potent their breath is with
aerosolized virus and i think that we're
still understanding that
there's also the cross-sectional or you
know instantaneous
infectiousness that an individual can
have which may be changing throughout
the day and so it matters when your last
test was timed and how quickly you're
getting your pco pcr results back
um but uh then also behavioral factors
like you know how
cl what's the proximity to other people
in what type of environment
how many unique individuals are you
mixing with is a different number of
unique individuals every day or are you
mixing with the same people unmasked
every single day these are are a lot of
the attributes that we have to factor
into our equations
so i want to go over with you the the
four pillars that i believe are really
essential for these private businesses
uh who many many of whom i i work with
regularly
who are the ones actively designing and
implementing protocols
to keep their
casts players staff crew
musicians safe
as they do these large events so my
focus isn't
uh i'll tell you a little more about
what we do for those essential uh
employees of of these of these live
large group gatherings
and from an audience's perspective i
think that we've it's much easier to
handle since they can continue to wear
masks uh or we can you know we can
mandate back proof of vaccination
but really the risks for for people who
to do their job they have to be indoors
unmasked um you know this
there's a whole other level of of risk
so the first thing of the four things
that i want to tell you is just
vaccination
now
different groups have have chosen
different strategies and many of this
has actually been led not by the
businesses themselves but by the labor
unions
so i often am brought in as the
scientific uh expert in collective
bargaining uh between different unions
uh and i think that this has been you
know very contentious but i've been so
grateful that our government has led
by demonstrating that
their their own
willingness to require vaccination for
many types of government employees and
health workers
so the first thing is just everyone
needs to be vaccinated
but i think that a lot of the education
that i do
with these groups is about what
vaccination gains us and what it does
not
gain us
so many people in the general public
still believe
that vaccination completely protects you
from
becoming infected
and being able to spread it to other
people and so i hear a lot of um you
know even vips in in these different
organizations say like well no i don't
need to wear a mask because i'm
vaccinated
yet
you know i still i myself and many of my
on the ground investigations i'm still
seeing super spreading events
among fully vaccinated groups
and so a lot of the work that we have to
do is helping the general public
understand that these vaccines are
incredibly effective
at preventing
hospitalization and death
and protecting our body by training it
to be ready to fight off symptoms
but the
likelihood that it's going to reduce our
risk of becoming infected
i mean
that that benefit may only last three
two or three months
after vaccination and then as i'll show
you with some nba data on uh natural
reinfection at the end you know it's
beginning to look like a similar amount
of people are becoming
reinfected and susceptible
and transmissible um
in the months after vaccination
the the second pillar that i really
believe is going to
have tremendous benefit not just for
live events
like for leisure and sports and
entertainment but also really for
corporate office spaces
is air filtration and air quality and
ventilation so number two really is
ventilation
so the
the components that that i see for these
events
as being incredibly important the the
three different parts of it are
ventilation
so hvac systems bringing in and mixing
fresh outside air and upgrading these
hvac systems to incorporate merv 13
filters or higher
now you can have
six to eight air changes per hour in
your large space and that can be great
but it you could have a hundred air
changes an hour and it still probably
wouldn't protect you from becoming
affected from the person just standing
right next to you without a mask on
and so
we need more than just an hvac system
with great filters inside of it
so the second part of
clean air that that i really recommend
and often add to modify the spaces these
spaces that people are working in uh are
portable air filters now
hepa is great
more than necessary i think to to filter
out coronavirus from the air you really
just need more 13 or higher
but these are key especially for places
like locker rooms or
small offices that have low ceilings or
dressing rooms
these are all places that we've
identified as being high risk for
transmission and it's through recycling
and purifying the air in those rooms
that we can supplement and enhance the
efficiency of the hvac system in the
building
and then the third tool that we have
really within this clear category is
just using fans you know i'm just saying
30 dollar box bands have been an
incredible tool
and i like to use them in two ways one
of them is to create turbulence in the
room and you know mix up the air in the
room
so i often like to say you know if you
can smell my fart and you can catch my
covid
just to help these groups
get the concept
of an aerosolized cloud and the types of
risk that that you might have
they still often think that it's just
proximity to other people but i've seen
many transmissions you know for example
um
one risky area i've seen are
recording boosts so for example vocal
recording booths are tiny boosts that
have no ventilation at all on purpose
because you know they don't want any
sound to come in and change the
recording
and you know someone could come into a
recording studio and take their mask off
and sing their heart out for an hour and
then leave and a couple hours later
another person can walk into that same
vocal recording booth and still you know
walk into this cloud of aerosolized
virus hanging in the air
and so fans position strategically
outside of faces pointing in create the
turbulence then to dilute uh and spread
apart that cloud so that as someone
walks into a space or through a space
the
the air that they're breathing in would
have a lower concentration of
aerosolized virus per breath and lower
the likelihood of that individual
becoming infected
so i often use them for to create that
turbulence and then the other way that
we use bands is really strategically for
example uh directionally controlling the
air so in long hallways where i notice
there are low ceilings it's a high
traffic area and there's thick stagnant
air because there are no windows
anywhere near this you know this is off
this could be underground at a stadium
this could be you know in backstage in
an old broadway theater
we can use bands strategically to
identify which end of that long hallway
has the cleanest air now let's put a big
box fan on that side so we're
directionally blowing the air
across and down that hallway
you know thinking about the movement of
air also has been incredibly challenging
and important for the safety of
musicians
um so i get a lot of questions and work
closely with musicians it's very easy to
help guitar players and piano players
because they can continue to wear a mask
while they do their jobs
but for
players of wind instruments and brass
instruments
it takes a lot more care and attention
to both do routine
frequent pcr testing to make sure that
those individuals are
confident about their negative status
before performance begins
or concert begins
as well as really inspecting the
ventilation system and movement of air
around those musicians
both to protect them from audience
members and to protect the audience from
a musician in the small
very small chance we hope that one would
be infectious and unaware
so this is just a
diagram to show how you know there's
been a lot of research done about these
about how the aerosol
virus or how aerosolization uh with
covid works and how it's even changed
with different variants
you we do know that the alpha and delta
strains
are
aerosolizing
in smaller particle sizes and traveling
longer distances than the original
lineage a that we saw in the beginning
of 2020
and you know there are a lot of endorsed
resources
uh where as an economist
making recommendations for
different
you know
hepa or merv 13 great air filters you do
have to weigh the costs and the benefits
so it's often
you know you can you can get great air
filters from between 200 to 500. they
vary depending on the size of the room
that they're intended to filter for
and have other attributes that people
are looking for such as the sound
so you can pay less to get one that's
noisier but if you're going to be
filming uh or
playing instruments then there are often
in the groups that i work with a lot of
sensitivities to sound and willingness
to pay more for for quieter units
so that second point was the first
vaccination then ventilation
and third is testing
now i've talked about testing a lot
before because we learned so much from
the nba and and what's possible with
testing and you know from from my seat
as
uh an economist where i i'm off pre
pandemic was doing a lot of models to
inform you know what's the value based
price for a new vaccine
or the price for a new drug or how
should we price this new diagnostic test
in order to do that we have to break
down what the dimensions are of value
that that product brings
and so as we think about
workplaces and private businesses
implementing their own
testing programs for their employees
then you know we have to be able to
understand what are the decisions that
they're trying to inform with that type
of workplace surveillance
and how can they reduce uncertainty in
those decisions or gain the confidence
that their workplace is safe
while also trying to minimize costs and
the budget impact of that
so really
you know the accuracy is incredibly
important now
the
for for many of these groups uh the
accuracy may not matter very much if you
have a lot of substitutes available for
that position
so if this is something like
an usher
for one of these events you may have
a willingness to accept something that
is less accurate like
a rapid antigen test
uh or
well there's a there's a lot of less
accurate tests available because maybe
there are plenty of other ushers that
that you could bring in but you may not
be willing to accept a rapid test in one
of your most important players or cast
members right before a performance
because they're incredibly valuable for
for the success of that event
and so that's where you might be willing
to pay much more for an incredibly
accurate result uh you know specifically
um you know an rna result so a molecular
result instead of an antigen
and i think that the target also matters
a lot because we have seen success
across all of the different indus uh the
uh types of businesses i'm talking about
now
in the detection of people uh being
infected before they become infectious
now i do think that this is one of the
distinguishing features of
workplaces where people have to be
indoors unmasked around each other in
small rooms
that
where there could be a high transmission
risk
and
this type of frequent testing or daily
pcr testing we've demonstrated over and
over again really can identify someone
as being positive
when they have a ct that's well above 30
and we can isolate that individual
before they become contagious to other
people
and i think that that's been one of the
keys to the success of containing uh
positive cases and preventing an
outbreak from occurring
uh you know with specimen type i think
that you know we've seen a lot more
acceptability and demand for saliva
based tests
and you know i've seen a lot of
variability and technician swab
technique of self-collection swab
concerns when the individual really does
not want to be positive and may not be
providing a thorough swab for their own
interests
when it really is of the community's
interests to be certain about it
and also the invasiveness of just people
getting tired of swabbing every single
day and preferring to sit
so a lot more demand for that
but we also want to pick and recommend
testing technologies that have an
adequate supply
and i think that many in the u.s have
felt the
pain of the supply shortages recently
with
many of the rapid tests that are
available
and you know we have to keep the costs
down i think this is where we're seeing
pooling becoming
not just accepted but again an increase
in demand from these groups to do
pooling um where with i think that that
is often what i'm seeing now to be able
to get the the frequency um
and make make the testing programs like
this sustainable while they're still
needed
and also from testing this is a photo of
just a board game that i made for one of
the broadway casts that i'm working with
they really struggled to understand what
happens if i'm positive when do i get to
come back to work
and it allowed the the entire production
to be able to
simulate through a game
how many people would need to test
positive
before we would need to cancel a show
because we wouldn't have enough human
bodies and subs and swings to be able to
bring in
so
you know this brings us to this is just
a picture i think that captures both the
the what testing can look like in a
workplace for one of these live events
and it also shows
the number four pillar that i think is
incredibly important and that is
high quality
genuine uh kn95 like masks
so
masks are incredibly important we all
know masks are important but i really do
believe that to bring large numbers of
people indoors together
in risky settings that many employers
are making a conscious choice to use k
95 masks instead of surgical and cloth
masks
and you know i'm seeing this really as a
risk mitigation
strategy that's used more for
being chosen by groups like uh that
if you cancel it will cost a lot of
money i'm not seeing many private
businesses like uh or retail locations
or corporate offices choose k 95 i think
that they're still keeping
options open for whatever people feel
most comfortable in but i do see
the
incredible success of filtering out the
virus and the main challenge has been in
the education of how to get good fit and
that that is really uh an important part
of the effectiveness of these things
so of all those you know i just told you
about
the components that i think are really
important
which are
ventil or vaccination
ventilation
testing and masking
and the implications for offices and
retail stores are um you know quite
quite relevant
i think in in other types of more common
workplaces where you may have a thousand
people gathering together every single
day in a corporate office
i i often don't recommend the
daily pcr testing because it just seems
very excessive um but i do think that i
do see many corporate offices now
in setting up testing programs just so
that their employees have access
to on-site specimen collection for
affordable pcr testing
and this has been really essential when
positive cases in the workplace do
happen so that the next time people come
in they can just you know give a saliva
sample as they walk in
and the workplace can continue to
monitor and make sure that
that everyone is negative so just
enabling the testing
to allow that continued productivity
as an alternative to
going into quarantine and waiting it out
so let's talk about some of the
the hot topics that are are still being
debated uh and you know i put a long
list down here just to to give you an
idea of the things that are are not
agreed on yet by different groups uh
that that don't have clear answers and
i'll you know discuss
just a couple here that are highlighted
in bold uh but we can use the q a time
if any of these other ones are of
interest to you
please throw it in the chat and we can
we can discuss
but a lot of what i hear is when can we
use quantitative pcr results you know ct
scores are
so incredibly helpful to understand if
someone was infectious at the time that
you swabbed them
but it's they're really supposed to just
be for research purposes only and the
fda has not authorized any of these
tests for stars kobe 2 to be able to
return that ct value to the patient
because they're
not enough is known to have confidence
that that should be guiding any of the
the treatment decision making for for an
individual patient
but what i am seeing a lot of are
epidemiologists in the field using these
ct scores to guide the response during
an outbreak and to help guide confidence
in containment
so you know if you were to in one day
identify
ten people who are positive
and you can see that
nine out of ten have a ct of you know 31
and higher and one person has a ct of 14
then it becomes much easier to
start putting the pieces together of
what might have happened in that super
spreading event
and i continue to get a lot of questions
about you know how long should we keep
people out of work once they do become
positive
so
that's where um
you know cdc tells us 10 days of
self-isolation
but it's actually the labor unions that
i'm seeing are adding on more
restrictions even then than cdc's
guidance so many
groups require
a clinic visit with their health care
provider to get clearance before they're
allowed to come back to work uh you know
i personally
don't think that that's a very good
strategy at this point in the pandemic
you know we already have limited
constrained healthcare resources right
now because of the burden of covid that
i think that it can be unnecessary to
take a a healthy person after they are
no longer contagious and
use the health care system for foreign
approval it could even put someone more
at risk going to a clinic after recovery
from coping just to become infected with
something else
and i think it's also very tragic when
i've seen many groups where their
employees do not have health insurance
so after being unemployed for 18 months
during the pandemic return to work
become positive they're out of work then
for 10 days unpaid for 10 days don't
have health insurance and the gating to
come back to work is a
health care clinic visit just to get
clearance
so you know i think we there are still a
lot of
policies and clear scientific
recommendations that need to be made so
that
employers and unions and non-scientists
can understand what the crystal cut
criteria should be for an individual to
return back to work safely that doesn't
put unneeded you know
financial
or you know health risks um onto these
employees to get back to work
so i'm just going to wrap up now
with
us looking back again towards the nba
like i said before just one of the most
incredible
leaders both
just in the development of policy and
the value of health of their players
um
to show some of the data from the most
recent paper that has come out
on reinfections
and you know this is among
you know mainly young
healthy men
and we're seeing the
um
infections
go to um
to you know ranging from
like most of them are all um more than a
hundred days after their first initial
infection
uh so let's see i think i actually have
the average so the the average time was
152 days was when they became
re-infected after their first infection
now if you look down on here there is
one case case number seven at the bottom
who's very different than the others and
i would like to highlight from the
beginning that um this individual became
reinfected very very shortly after their
first infection
and
you know it was confirmed through
sequencing that these were two different
viruses but
it was
learned that this individual had an
immune compromising condition
and that that is likely why they
experienced
a very different set of symptoms during
their first infection
then
did not have antibodies following it and
became reinfected again with a a
meaningfully high viral load
but aside from case number seven
um the
average peak viral load for these
individuals
when they were re-infected was about 28
a ct value of 28 and compared to the
same group of people in their first
infections had a
mean peak viral load of 22
of ct of 22. so
that you know roughly translates to the
re-infections had a slightly
lower viral load the second time they
became infected but it was still within
from for
most of them still within a range that
we would consider to be infectious to
other people
we did it is noticeable too that the
days from
reinfection onset to being cleared with
two negative test results consecutively
was a shorter time so clearance happened
sooner
and i think that this is really
interesting because it it really
parallels exactly what i'm seeing in
outbreak investigations
of people who are vaccinated compared to
unvaccinated so there are a lot of
parallels that we can learn between
those
so you know in conclusion i i just
wanted to say that you know it
it's really hard work i think taking all
of what we know about the science um and
the meat of the scientific presentations
that are in the the rest of this
coronavirus virtual event series
and translating it into public policy
for the real world you know there are
still going to be bars and restaurants
open and full of people there will still
be people that are choosing to remain
unvaccinated
and you know i think to me one of the
most important metrics that i like to
follow is how many cities there are in
our country that do not have any
capacity in the icu
because at that point it becomes a
weakness and vulnerability of our health
care system that if someone were to have
a heart attack or get in a car accident
and not be able to access the health
care we they need
to me is is not acceptable and so i
think that we will continue to work in
in developing
smart responsible public health policies
both at a
national level at a local level
but really you know i just want to
encourage you and recognize all of the
private businesses that are really
trying to do the difficult work of
taking
general public health guidance and
making it practical for the situation
that they're living in
so with that i'd like to just thank
everyone for joining and sticking with
me
and i'd love to hear uh any of your
questions
thank you
and thank you dr adamson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of our
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in from our audience
our first question
what workplace conditions should require
wearing a k and 95 mask
great question
um so i like to think of those four
pillars
as
a table
and you you can take away one of the
legs but if you take away two of the
legs it all falls down
so in my mind a high quality mask like a
kn-95
is
definitely needed if you
are uncertain about the vaccination
status of the people around you
there is
no ventilation in the space that you're
in it's an indoor space or you know you
have to work in an environment that
doesn't have filters there's no exterior
doors or windows that can open
and you don't know what the infection
status statuses of the people around you
so if there's no routine testing program
you're just you know
in
to do your job
trapped in a really small space without
fresh air and you don't know if people
are vaccinated and you don't know their
testing results that's a situation that
i would say you should definitely wear
or employers should definitely mandate k
95 masks to mitigate risks
now
i would say the
many employers
will choose k 95 masks in high stakes
situations where they really don't want
individuals to become infected so much
because they are they can't work from
home to do their jobs
or the entire you know event or
something would would have to be
canceled so some
uh will just do it as an extra
mitigating step
but absolutely in the first set of
conditions i described k 95 masks would
be necessary
thank you so much our next question from
our audience what is the ideal frequency
of pcr testing for workplace
surveillance
this is a great one you know i think
that
it really is dependent on on two
different factors one
what's the burden of covet in the
community so what's the likelihood that
people in that workplace are going to
get infected in well so i like to divide
it up in
you can get infected in your household
through the people you live with you can
get infected in your community uh from
you know going to a dinner party uh or
you can get infected in your workplace
where you spend a lot of your time and
workplace policies can do a ton
to
mitigate the risk of a transmission
happening at work
but there's not much a workplace can do
to
prevent you becoming infected in your
home or in your community
and so the likelihood that you show up
at work positive
that really
is is one of the main factors
determining how frequently someone
should be testing
the other
element of what goes into the decision
of frequency is when was the last
positive case in that workplace
and so if this workplace hasn't had any
positives in several weeks or in a month
you know i think that that i am seeing
many that that are slowing down the
frequency of testing so maybe they test
once a week just to to see any and
they're still not getting any so maybe
they just test
um you know once every two weeks but
once that uh if you start testing every
two weeks and you start seeing cases pop
up again
that tells you that now you're not
testing enough to pick up these
infections or you're not testing enough
to understand is that spread that's
happening in my workplace
or are these just infections happening
around the same point in time but
they're just both you know they're
unrelated to each other
so
many workplaces in just setting up a
testing program might make it available
to their employees once a week but then
really have it there as a way to respond
once positive cases start happening
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
our next question from an audience
member
this person says comment in question on
spreading of covid for individuals who
are the majority of the vulnerable
population the effort to just get a test
as soon as possible is daunting cvs
hardly has anything sooner than three
days then add two days to get results
back the sooner you need the test the
tougher it is
the easy test centers take a week to get
those results back this is really
working in favor of the virus what is
being done to cut this time that it
takes to get a test and the results to a
day or two
this is such a great question
uh you know i think that
uh you know our um
our
federal government is doing the efforts
that it can to increase the supply and
lower the cost yet we're still feeling
the pain and it's very different
depending on where you are in the
country
and as an economist i like to think you
know it is kind of inefficient for all
of us to be working as individuals in
trying to get access and pay for these
tests
and so i'm seeing a lot of success
when businesses
and
when the employer
is directly contracting with a lab
to create access to
a big supply of tests at a bulk
discounted rate
and so this ends up being a win-win
because the employer both you know
they're they're making sure that their
employees have access to tests they're
getting the cheapest price possible
they're ensuring that they have the
supply because they're pre-contracting a
minimum quantity of tests that will be
used and then contractually they're able
to say that test results have to come
back within a certain amount of time
otherwise they're not going to pay for
them and they also many of them include
contractually the option to pay a
premium to get the results back even
sooner
so i do think that it's hard for
the federal government to
i mean it's a tough job to create an
abundant supply of tests for people to
seek individually
and so i am seeing a lot of success for
with employers being the ones to to
create that access uh and
faster turnaround time
thank you so much now how should private
businesses define a threshold for when
to close a workplace
oh this is this is a spicy one um you
know i first
with many of the groups that i worked
with at the beginning
the threshold was just defined for them
by
when you run out of humans to do that
job you have to close
but then depending on the organization
um
groups started just figuring out or
having
quite a depth of people who could
replace those roles and so we don't want
to end up in a place where we are
creating a workplace environment where
spreading is actively happening all the
time you know and it's just a continuous
outbreak but we're just putting more and
more bodies in to replace the ones that
are in isolation we don't want that
um so i think that a threshold really is
um related to containment so that you
know it's okay to backfill positive
cases but if you're starting to see
tertiary and quaternary infections um
from a spreading event that happened in
the workplace then to me that flag's you
know an area for serious concern and
um
the
you know further investigation so this
is where many of the groups that i work
with and and i'm seeing this used by a
lot more epidemiologists or are what we
call precision epidemiology
investigations and that's where we use
genomic sequencing
to
sequence all of the positive cases
within a workplace that
are clustered around the same
period of time or maybe the same area of
a workplace or a production you know or
a team
and through sequencing we then just
compare the viruses to understand
how similar they are to each other
and estimate the likelihood that we
think that the transmission had happened
in the
the production or the team within the
workplace
or under or or be able to tell you know
oh these viruses are totally different
from each other you know we're pretty
sure that these two people just
separately became infected in their own
communities and then came into work
positive around the same point in time
and if it's the latter then great news
you know safety policies are working you
know people will become positive you
know from
home and community
but
then if you find out that oh these are
almost identical viruses
um
among this whole group of people
then that's the time where it becomes
the employer's responsibility to closely
review the safety protocols and make
revisions to patch them up and ensure
that a spreading event like that won't
happen again
or reduce the risk
thank you so much dr adamson we have
time for two more questions our next
question what do people need to do to
get back to work after natural infection
and the second part of this is when is a
10-day isolation negative test and
healthcare provider clearance necessary
so i mentioned that i i
you know really don't think that the
clearance is necessary for people who
were asymptomatic or who had mild
symptoms that that improved over time
but i definitely don't think we should
be gaining on having to have a negative
test before we go back to work i mean
i've seen people who are testing
positive for months and months sometimes
more than 100 days and we can't make
them be out of work for 100 days so
but i am seeing many union protocols
just out of you know not under
conceptually understanding the
difference between a positive pcr test
result and a level of virus that
of
you know active infectious virus that
could be a risk to others
yet in the same way
i do see many opportunities to bring
essential
employees back sometimes sooner than 10
days
now the
i think that this really is then gated
on multiple negative pcr tests 24 hours
apart at least
you know consecutively
so that if an individual does become
positive for example someone who's fully
vaccinated they might test positive for
one or two days and then go negative
they don't experience any symptoms at
all and the negative multiple negative
test results tell us that you know
they're not infectious to others
i don't consider that to be a false
positive case i really think it is
becoming more of a profile of what i see
among vaccinated breakthrough infections
and the 10-day isolation then is not
always absolutely necessary
thank you so much we have time for one
more question let's talk about children
should unvaccinated kids test to stay in
school instead of quarantine after
exposure and can parents of infected
children return to work
i love this dilemma um because
i think that with kids
the same concepts apply in school we
want great ventilation we want doors to
be open windows to the outside to be
open we want to bring air filters into
the classroom we want certain routine
surveillance testing to pick up kids as
soon as they're positive
but and we want masking you know i think
that masks are
some it's been amazing how tolerant
children have been
to to wearing masks when they go to
school
but you know we know the kids
are
still less likely to become infected
less likely to pass it on to other
people and experience symptoms and i
really do think that test to stay
is going to create more benefit for
children than
you know assuming that all children
should quarantine after an exposure in
the classroom i think that we have to
make we have to weigh the risks and the
benefits here for kids and i think that
you know the social emotional academic
development of kids is incredibly
important and we've seen this modeled
out in the uk not modeled out but
actually tested out in ran in a
randomized experiment
to show that
um
they they randomized um
schools so that some of them quarantined
all children when there was a positive
and some of them tested all of them
after an exposure and they found out
that that with testing to stay children
spend a meaningful
amount of additional days in the
classroom and they did not see
a higher rate of new cases because of it
and so if we can get the access
to affordable testing for school
districts i think this can be an
incredible tool to keep kids in the
classroom
absolutely thank you dr adamson for this
great presentation today and for
important research do you want to
provide any closing remarks before we go
no just thank you to lab roots for
inviting me to to be part of this uh
coronavirus event
and thank you again for your
presentation today and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed via
the speaker
using your contact information you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until october 2023
labrits will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone stay safe
bye